the preview for the second-last American
Horror Story is here and I gotta say I'm
not that impressed and I'll tell you why
as always if you haven't checked it out
I've left a link in the description so
give it a look and come on back
it looks like Richards favorite rock
star is on his way and my guess is that
if Billy actually shows up as a
character he'll be played by a returning
HS alum I know he said he's not in this
season but I think Evan Peters would
play a great Billy Idol we have Richard
checking out Billy's setup he'll
probably do everything in his power to
meet him and judging by the amount of
Billy Idol gear in the background I'd be
surprised if he doesn't show up as a
character
Ricky shows off his Satan tattoo to
another roadie and this is where I start
to get a little frustrated Donna and
Brooke are at a diner which leads me to
believe they might not make it to
Redwood until the end of the episode
I'll be honest their storyline last
episode although fun was basically
filler and now I'm guessing the writers
are stretching the story in order to fit
everything into the final episode and it
makes more sense now why they went from
ten episodes to nine probably because
they ran at a story now don't get me
wrong it's not that I want less episodes
I just rather have eight or nine great
episodes instead of ten with some
fillers but it's seeming to me that this
season would have been more suitable for
eight episodes to make the plot even
tighter Donna and Brooke are in new
outfits since last we saw them so this
may take place the day after the events
of episode 7 and Donna tells Brooke that
she's a final girl although the final
girl trope has been around for decades
it was actually first coined in the 1992
book men women and chainsaws gender in
the modern horror film it outlines how
the final girl was traditionally the one
to confront the killer and survive but
it's also the one who is morally
superior to others for example one who
refuses drugs like Brooke did in Episode
one or abstains from sex like how Brooke
was saving herself for marriage now
Brooke did have sex with Ray but since
he's a ghost technically I think that
still makes her a virgin we have Mr
jingles take down Ricky but look at this
shot here I'm pretty sure this is just
these stunt doubles and I'm thinking too
hard about this we have three
your beefs still to deal with in these
final two episodes jingles and Ricki
Margaret and Brooke and Montana and
Brooke so it is possible the final
showdown between jingles and Ricky could
happen here but my guess is that it will
segue into something bigger for the
final episode I'm really hoping they can
find some way to connect the Satanism
and the curse into the bigger narrative
of the season our final shot is up
Margaret and Courtney finding the Akagi
goo-goo bodies but my guess is that
Margaret will want to keep this under
wraps until the festival is over overall
I found this the most disappointing
preview so far particularly because it
really didn't give us any new insights
into what's to come but that could be
because with only two episodes left they
want to keep most of their secrets
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and let me know in
the comments below what you think might
happen next as always you can follow me
on Twitter at think story whitey and
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much